um Joe you went to Korea for the first
time didn't you I wanted to ask you
about that finally went to Korea yeah uh
just for like three days for Rocky's
birthday
um yeah it was freaking awesome yeah a
lot I mean big surprise Curry is kind of
cool yeah it is it is wow the big
surprise the food there was freaking
amazing wow no one knew that before yeah
but um yeah I don't know we were just
like just being tourists for three days
just because I like I've never been
there arky's never been there and it's
so close to Japan yeah right yeah yeah
it's like like it takes longer to get to
all you know what than it does to Korea
exactly and I've been walking out like
five times so it's like okay I have no
excuse I gotta go whereabouts did you
say uh mostly just in Seoul yeah I think
because we only had three days so I
figured like traveling yeah I was like
should we take a day to like you know go
to like uh you know Busan or like
Gangnam or like other places like that
but I'm just like yeah I just kind of
wanted to explore actual Soul because
it's a lot bigger than I thought it was
going to be yeah it's [__] massive
yeah yeah because like you see it on the
map right and it's just like oh it's
like not that much different to like
Tokyo for example yeah it's so much
bigger than that because like even if it
just seems down the road it's like oh
it's 20 minutes by train and I'm like
how does that how that work but yeah so
um because we have like a couple of
friends who like used to live in Korea
quite a long time so we were just like
just give us recommendations for like
the most touristy [__] we can do yeah
yeah um so we went to like you know the
Food Markets there and like uh you know
uh the I guess the equivalent of Tokyo
Tower in right in uh Seoul which called
the namsam tower I think it's cool
um yeah it was really cool just super
chill one thing that I was pleasantly
surprised about is that damn everyone
can speak English there yep that's
awesome it's yeah like I like even if
like you you walk into a store right and
immediately you know they greet you in
Korean but then the moment you start
speaking English they just switch
forward like to full on flow in English
and they're just like oh okay yeah sure
yeah I was surprised by that when I went
to Korea as well because there were
times there was like a few times where I
was just like being sitting with like uh
staring at like the train map trying to
figure out how to get to the place we
want to go yeah and every time we stood
there for like more than a minute
minutes someone came over and was like
oh do you need help in like yeah perfect
English and would explain how to get
there in perfect English and I'm just
like yeah I'm going to see League of
Legends okay do you know what stadium
that is yeah I'm trying to watch Imagine
Dragons actually yeah
so surprising that like I think just not
only the fact that English is such a a
pro a prevalent language that's spoken
there but also just like one massive
difference I saw especially compared to
Japan was not only that but also just
how much people are okay with being on
camera because Aki and I were both
vlogging the entire our entire trip and
you know when you go to like the food
markets for example and you know you'd
point the camera at like the food and
stuff like that yeah and I think my like
Japanese brain kicks in yeah I'm just
like I'm not I'm gonna try and avoid
getting random people yeah into my
videos because they might not like it no
there were so many instances where I
would point you know the camera towards
like a food store or something right and
the the man or the woman behind it would
just be like
yay like that was so chill and okay with
being on camera and when we were at this
random food store there was this Korean
couple that just started talking to us
again in perfect English yeah and was
just like oh I wouldn't you know I
wouldn't recommend that if you don't
like spicy food in the most like and I
thought like oh have you lived outside
of Korea before and they're like never
left the city but like the wiser English
so good and it's just I I got a glimpse
of what Japan might be if English was as
commonly used as it was in Korea right
because immediately as a tourist I felt
so much more comfortable like just kind
of talking to people and like I wasn't
as I mean no obviously obviously I was
trying to also practice my horrible
Korean as well yeah but at the same time
if it failed then there was always that
that Fail-Safe of all they can speak
moderately do you have a safety net yeah
they have a safety net which I feel a
lot of people who come to Japan as a
tourist on 4 emotionally don't really
get yeah
um purely because English is just not as
commonly spoken and you get that like
honey like face right every time you go
I mean I mean I think we are very very
lucky to know English because it's such
an OP language if you're traveling about
yeah uh and you forget sometimes that
you know uh you forget sometimes when
you travel there are some places that
just don't know much English at all and
Japan is like one of those countries in
comparison to some other major cities
and then a lot of like other like let's
say culturally famous places Japan
doesn't really speak that much English
uh China's a big one as well it's like
it's like if you go to like any major
shiny City a lot of people there do not
speak English and you forget okay
English is only popular in certain
places in the world yeah and there are
some places and you've gotten used to
being able to just like kind of like
push through with you know really slow
English in some places but in Japan it's
a lot harder than other places where
everyone should learn charades
professionals just in case they don't
speak English then at least be like all
right I know how to symbolize what
you're doing like yeah can I have
chicken that's not good stick on chicken
please stick on chicken stick on chicken
no but uh obviously you know the food
was freaking amazing there like
everything you have a Korean Fried
Chicken of course
three times though like I think I would
have come back with 15 like points of
higher cholesterol I mean I would hit it
every day I mean we only went once but
it's because we tried to have as as much
variety of cream food as possible so we
were just like we're just gonna try
everything
um and we saved the Korean chicken till
last because it was like you know it was
gonna slap yeah it's it's pretty hard to
mess up and I I know like and also my
Korean friend was like go to this place
because this is the best place to go and
we went there man I I had a food Wars
moment I I was like three quarters child
at least eating this chicken and it was
amazing Fried Chicken Man the Korean
like the the barbecue you that the K
barbecue that was also amazing and so
cheap too yeah it's insane like I
thought eating out in Japan was cheap
but then when you're going in and out in
Korea it's like it's even cheaper it's
even cheaper yeah it's crazy because
like even the food stalls and stuff like
that I I get confused initially because
you know compared to the Yen the the
Korean won is like one extra digit so
300 Yen in Japan which is about three
dollars it's three thousand Korean won
yeah so when you when I initially look
at the prices my heart just goes but
then I realize it's like oh wait it's
like three bucks yeah so yeah yeah I got
some of the most like amazing like
street food there
um like everyone was so like hospitable
and like friendly and they were so like
eager to be on camera as well like I had
this one woman who like dragged Aki and
I into this uh into the seafood uh place
and she's just like Lord of sin we were
like all right let's let's see what
happens yeah and she like dragged us
into her like her shop and she just
started serving us this like fresh crab
meat with like
um with uh you know like on a bed of
rice with like a little bit of kimchi on
top yeah and it was the most amazing
thing ever and she was she was she was
plating it up like she was [__]
serving it to Gordon Ramsay she was just
like okay okay I will I will do the best
thing for you here you go camera camera
look at this look like she kept pointing
to the camera being like focus on this
focus on this right I'm like what are
you a YouTuber it's like a food review
Channel happening yeah super sucks I
guess you're always in Japan and and
rightfully so you should assume that
people just don't want to be on camera
yeah yes that's the correct way of
assuming yeah yeah um but that is yes we
had to think that they're just like oh
I'm the movie star get me on camera how
do I look flip the camera around let me
see it oh yeah okay yeah yeah no
honestly likes a lot of them were like
that and you know that and it's more
understandable if it's like younger
people right but a lot of these people
running these food stores in in Seoul uh
of the older generation which you would
think is not that comfortable with being
on camera right but I guess you know the
place we went to
um the the famous food markets there
there's been so many like food channels
like doing videos there and TV station
doing videos there so I guess they're
just like used to being on camera now
but but I also think
um this is total conjecture by the way I
think
um that when I went to Korea it it felt
it it felt so Eerie right because it was
so like you you go you go to Seoul and
you look around you're like this feels
very much like Tokyo yeah like it like I
remember saying to Sydney if you had
just dropped me in a round placed in
Seoul and dropped me in a random place
in um in Tokyo if I did not recognize
kanji at all or anything like that I I
would have a trouble distinguishing from
like first looks which city I'm actually
in yeah
um they look eerily similar but then you
walk around and Korean people from what
I experienced were just a lot less
reserved than Japanese people right
Japanese people are very very reserved
um and I think I think I I would I would
like to Guess that internet culture has
is just a lot more prevalent in Korean
culture oh I mean it's it's the it's
literally the uh country that kind of
like birthed Esports right that's why
Esports had his like
um had its major Roots put into it so I
would imagine that just the whole
culture over there is much more aware of
just in the internet age and just the
online culture oh yeah I believe so yeah
that's the only country on earth that is
I think fast internet than Japan yeah
yeah I think it has one of the fastest
internet connections in the world I
think it's number one yeah
I can't remember if it still is but a
while back I mean I certainly had no
problems connecting to any Wi-Fi that's
for sure it's so publicly available yeah
exactly yeah these people are taking the
drinking culture at all oh yeah of
course I did oh it is
they are brutal over there man holy [__]
I mean my only saving grace was that Aki
is not that much of a drink so I kind of
had like a scapegoat for that but my God
man like I just even going to like the
key barbecue and just looking across the
room yeah and just seeing like 20 Soju
bottles for like three people yeah that
are just sitting there and they're just
laughing and drinking away like it's
nothing I'm like bro I feel sorry for
the doctors that have to check up on
your goddamn liver every year like yeah
brutal so juicy oh my God yeah but um I
did though I guess like the the one
aspect I guess the friendly uh the The
Stranger friendliness in Korea that
almost backfired in a way was it was I
think it was like the second night we're
in Seoul and uh we were just kind of
walking back from a restaurant just you
know chatting away or whatever
um and this random dude just came up to
me random Korean dude and I knew
something was kind of weird because he
kind of flagged me down yeah and then he
was like oh hey man how's it going he
kind of spoken like a slight Australian
british-esque accent but the kind where
it's like a bad impression right oh okay
and at first I thought it was a fan yeah
right because he just came up to me not
so nonchalantly yeah and so I responded
like I would if it was a fan I shook his
hand I was like yeah man how's it going
you know like how's your night being
blah blah blah and then randomly he just
points towards this building in the
distance and he goes I work there
I went cool
uh didn't ask but I'm glad I'm glad
you're happy that you work at that
particular establishment that I am
unaware of and then he just started
asking me questions like oh where are
you guys from you know blah blah blah
and that's when I realized oh he's not a
fan he's just a random dude who just
stopped me and I guess just wanted to
start talking to me for some reason so
that that happened to me twice when I
was yeah I was in South like three days
as well yeah and people like that I just
randomly obviously we look like tourists
and I think I don't know if it's normal
for locals to do this but especially I
felt like someone just wanted it felt
like someone just wanted to practice
their English right they saw a tourist
they were like all right boys it's time
and and unlike unlike you know Japanese
people where they're like very reserved
they're like you know can't talk to
random strangers yeah don't do that
don't don't break people's uh social
boundaries Koreans are just like you
know what I'm gonna I'm just gonna
strike up a conversation and see where
it takes me honestly and and I think the
only reason why he decided to start
talking to me in particular is because I
think he heard my accent and then he
mentioned to me that he lived in the UK
for a couple of years and that's how he
learned his English right and I was like
okay I mean good on you like you know
your your English is certainly better
than you know the average Korean that
I've talked to so far on this trip but
also it was at like 11 p.m on a side
street and my first instinct was this
guy's trying to [__] mug me
and I could see Aki's just like [__]
herself just being like get me the [__]
out of this conversation right now and
then I found a really weird when after
all of that just kind of Chit Chat
getting to know you know about him and
his supposed workplace yeah he was like
where are you staying
[Music]
and then that's when the red flag went
up and I was like uh and I just I just
mentioned some alcohol yeah yeah yeah I
just mentioned some other Hotel I'm like
oh it's like down there we gotta get the
train or whatever and he's like okay do
you want me to like take you to that
hotel
and I was like I'm good bro I'm that's a
no from me dog I I know my way we've
been here for a couple of days it's all
good and so I I started to get really
really worried yeah luckily he like left
me alone after that he was just like
okay have a good night mate and I was
like yeah yeah that didn't happen to me
yeah I was like yeah you too man and I
just [__] bolted across the road I'm
like please don't follow us but yeah
that was I it was it was scary but also
I don't know it was a little bit
endearing right yeah yeah you that is a
situation that you will Almost Never
encounter in Japan right especially if
the Japanese person is striking up the
conversation yeah that would never
happen that would never happen
absolutely no especially in Tokyo so
yeah it's pretty it's happened a few
times outside of Tokyo but not in Tokyo
no no it's happened to me in like all
soccer and stuff right where the
stranger friendliness is a little bit
better but yeah never in Tokyo